[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
débattre discuter et réfléchir sur les
grands enjeux qui font l'actualité
ce soir nous parlerons santé depuis les
années 90 octobre est consacrée à un
mois d'information de levée de fonds et
de sensibilisation contre le cancer du
sein
c'est octobre rose un mois qui revêt
cette année une dimension inédite avec
l'épidémie de covile 19 des examens de
suivi ont pris du retard des chirurgies
sont annulés selon une étude publiée par
les chercheurs de gustave roussy premier
centre de lutte contre le cancer en
europe les retards de prise en charge
causeront à 5 ans une surmortalité de
deux ans alors dans ce numéro nous
intéresserons donc à comment poursuivre
le dépistage et la politique de santé en
temps de crise sanitaire et trois
invités sont ce soir avec nous pour
échanger en visio le docteur aline kong
gynécologue obstétricien au centre
hospitalier de versailles bonsoir
bonsoir
le docteur agnès berne ou médecin
coordinateur pour l'essonne du centre
régional de coordination des dépistages
des cancers d'ile-de-france vos sorts
bonsoir et en plateau nous il ya tout
sol une des fondatrices de l'association
famine et aux mureaux une association
qui travaille notamment sur la
prévention santé des femmes bon soir
pour se rendre compte de l'importance du
dépistage on va débuter avec quelques
chiffres ce sont les chiffres de santé
publique france pour l'année 2018 il ya
eu près de 58 mille 500 nouveaux cas et
plus de 12000 et d'essai docteur agnès
berne où il faut le rappeler le cancer
du sein c'est la première cause de
mortalité par cancer chez la femme tout
à fait le cancer du sein la première
cause à la le premier cas cause de
cancer est la première cause de
mortalité chez la femme alors que c'est
un cancer qui s'y et les prêts à temps
est dépisté tôt à une survie à 5 ans de
plus de 82 99 % alors que si les
dépister enfin s'il est diagnostiqué
tard la survie est nettement moins bonne
doctor l une contre indiqué que selon
les chercheurs de gustave ou s'il est
rétabli
les retards de prise en charge
second à 5 ans une surmortalité de deux
ans est ce que c'est un sentiment
partagé par les équipes du centre
hospitalier de versailles où il faut
être moins inquiet que ça oui le
sentiment de retard de prise en charge
il existe il a été surtout notable va
après la période de mars à avril où là
il ya un arrêt copé des dépistages
effectivement des interventions annulée
et reportée
là où on était rentré dans une phase où
on avait reculé l'activité chirurgicale
et les gens sont de nouveau retournés
vers leur contrôle donc on a repris
l'activité mais effectivement on a noté
en tout cas j'ai douté moi dans mon
expérience propre à la rentrée des cas
diagnostiqué un petit peu plus
tardivement en tout cas des personnes
qui avaient commencé des bilans en début
d'année puis qui ont laissé très n'y ait
pas fait les blocs sic et qui se
retrouvent opérer une tout neuf mois
plus tard au lieu d'être et au moment du
diagnostic donc effectivement comme l'a
souligné le docteur bermuda un trou
retard de prise en charge entraîne des
diagnostics et les traitements à des
stades plus avancés et ce qui peut donc
rêver le pronostic de la maladie
donc là un instant t les rendez-vous de
l'espace de santé des femmes se passe
plutôt bien vous avez pu reprendre
correctement votre activité jusqu'au à
ce jour on va voir ce que ça donne pour
la suite mais volume en a repris
complètement l'activité et donc découpé
de chirurgie et de prise en charge
on a repris progressivement mais s'est
rapidement au mois de mai en reprenant
en priorité donc des interventions
chirurgicales de cancer dont vous n'avez
aucun report tous les cancers ont été
opérés et hilarante réformant fonctionne
pendant complètement normalement qui en
attend les consignes à venir pour la
suite voilà et bien sûr les cancers est
toujours prioritaire
alors depuis le conflit dont on entend
très régulièrement dans les médias que
les français auraient peur de se rendre
chez le médecin
nous avons posé la question à nos
téléspectateurs je propose de regarder
le résultat
la question était avez vous des craintes
à vous rendre chez un professionnel de
santé en cette période de crise
sanitaire
c'est le nom qu'ils l'emportent pour nos
téléspectateurs et pourtant en mai
dernier un sondage réalisé par la
fédération de l'hospitalisation privée
révélé qu'un tiers des français à
renoncer
consultez noria tous au avec votre
association vous êtes au plus près des
familles des patients est ce que il y à
une inquiétude aller voir son médecin ou
à se rendre à l'hôpital
oui aller voir son médecin il n'y a pas
de complication mais aller à l'hôpital
et à une complication il ya une
vraiment c'est la peur c'était la peur
qui bloque voilà c'est la possible
doctor who octobre euros c'est
l'occasion de rappeler que le coc vide
la copie des lames et les autres
maladies sont toujours présentes tout à
fait avec avec le confinement on a dû
arrêter le dépistage en france entière
et notamment en ile de france on en à
peu près dix semaines puisque c'était
pas la priorité est au moment de la
reprise les consignes nationales qui ont
été donnés c'était deux pour les
notamment les centres de radiologie
c'était d'abord de passer en priorité
les pales sens les patients
asymptomatiques ou les patients qui
avaient des hauts risques de cancer une
fête d'antécédents personnels ou
familiaux mais petit à petit en fait on
a rattrapé les femmes sont retournés se
faire dépister
mais le retour au dépistage je dirais à
une échelle normal par rapport à ce
qu'on observe sur la même période
les autres années s'est fait à partir du
mois de juillet donc on estime fin août
que en fait on a fait 75 % de l'activité
comparé à 2019
par contre depuis le mois de septembre
il ya une très forte activité on est à
peu près à 110 % de l'activité normale
de mammographie dans la région est bon
les femmes retournent faire des
mammographies donc ça c'est positif mais
voilà il faut vraiment y aller parce que
comme le disait le docteur alioune
combat style si on attend trop on risque
de perdre le bénéfice du dépistage
on sait que jusqu'à six semaines de
décalage dans le nez de dans le
diagnostic
il n'y a pas de perte de chance mais à
partir de six semaines et autour de 10
semaines et plus on sait que des tumeurs
qui était bénigne avec aucune risque de
métastase pouvez commencer à faire des
petites métastases qui aurait des
répercussions en fait pas forcément à
court terme mais à long terme à cinq ou
dix ans donc il faut que les femmes
continuent à se faire dépister
régulièrement tous les deux ans et si
elles ont pris du retard qu'elles
prennent rendez vous il ya un peu
d'attentes dans les centres de
radiologie puisque ben voilà il ya ces
retards à combler mais il faut pas
hésiter à prendre rendez vous
même s'il prend des coups et que dans un
mois ou un mois et demi par parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de femmes ne pas se
décourager et prendre son rendez vous dr
gomes que vous avez perdu certaines
patientes dans le sens où elle ne
revienne plus et vous n'arrivez pas à
les faire revenir ou vos patientes sont
conscientes qu'il faut être soigné être
accompagnés à l'orgue et du fait de
toutes les façons c'est celle que j'ai
déjà opéré d'un cancer et que je suis
donc elles ont quand même bien en tête
l'importance de 10 suivi de la
surveillance
donc ces patientes à elles sont vues
comme le dit dr perdons un petit retard
de deux dates souvent de mammographies
annuelles pour les surveillances d'un
antécédent de cancer ont été décalée de
quelques mois en raison du mobile et
puis des difficultés de après deux
rendez vous le temps des choses se
remettent en place mais elles ont au
maximum perdu quelques mois elles sont
bien quand même à jour de leurs bilans
après je pense qu'effectivement la
nécessité vraiment de doctes la santé
sur le dépistage ou pour les dépistages
des nouveaux cas et passion qui se sont
soumis à la déclarer qu'on crée t sont
quand même bien sensibiliser à l'intérêt
d'une surveillance rapprochée
par contre effectivement on a peut-être
un petit peu moins de dépistage précoce
et c'est tout l'intérêt de dépister les
lésions le plus tôt possible ses
patientes à ne se sachant pas à la de
peut-être voilà où passe à dans leurs
priorités de se faire dépister
et c'est vraiment le point qu'il faut
souligner puisque certaines passions de
la vienne avec des tumeurs plus avancé
et plus palpable dans celle là
effectivement elles ont un point d'appel
qui justifie qu'on soutient l'hôpital et
qui passe montre peut-être leur angoisse
d'autres choses mais toutes les
patientes sans aucun symptôme qui moment
se faire dépister ce sont celles là qui
sont à risque de retard de prise en
charge
il ya de tout cela allez si madame
vernon je voulais juste dire que
évidemment les centres de radiologie
elle applique toutes les consignes
nécessaires sanitaires les
les personnes en salles d'attentes ne
sont pas trop nombreuses et tout est
fait pour respecter les consignes par
rapport aux qu'ovide bien évidemment la
seule personne à qui on demande de
différer ce serait les personnes qui
seraient en rapport aurait eu un cas
contacts où seraient atteintes de cette
pathologie mais en dehors de ça il n'y a
pas de raison de différer son dépistage
l'idem j'imagine au centre hospitalier
de versailles
tout est mis en place pour rassurer et
faire attention vous faites attention à
vos patiente
oui bien évidemment c'est un centre
hospitalier
on applique strictement d'un sur toutes
les consignes et depuis les reprises des
consultations tout est fait évidement
dans les salles d'attentes pour les gens
en soient distanciés le plus possible
tout le monde porte le masque à ddd des
usa chat qui peut être délivré vraiment
très régulièrement dans l'hôpital dans
tous les couloirs et partout donc les
gens ne prennent pas un sur-risque à
venir à l'hôpital
au contraire et prénom sur l'espagne
menant pas où tu veux t'en passer en ont
besoin nourrie à tous où est ce que
votre association est plus que jamais
attentifs à ce que les femmes se fassent
suivre
vous avez du mal à les convaincre et
même votre association est un peu à
l'arrêt avec toute cette situation
l'association un pas là
à cause de la cobac 19 donc bon pour le
octobre reuzeau nous on a pensé ça ça
beaucoup depuis quelques mois le mois
d'octobre aviv qui arrive donc il ya
c'est le mois de c'est le mois 200
civils à la sensibilisation pour les
femmes que pour la mammographie et puis
il ya certaines femmes qui sont d'accord
pour aller se faire dépister à la
radiologie domus aurea destrier donc là
on peut se déplacer quand on a le
courrier on amène directement pour se
tester
mais il y a quelques dents plus c'est
difficile de les convaincre
parce que le mot hôpital aujourd'hui mon
médecin ça lui fait peur donc ne savent
pas s'ils vont chauffer encore d'autres
maladies les plus le ramener à la maison
tout ça il ya une méfiance à cause de la
cofidis dr comme vous le ressentez vous
sur le terrain
cette pas cette méfiance et cette peur
que peuvent avoir certaines patientes
maintenant puisque effectivement ceux
qui viennent c'est ceux qui ont franchi
un peu quels obstacles de la peur et ce
qu'ils doivent à revoir puisque on ne
les voit pas malheureusement mais je
pense que c'était surtout le cas
estimant peut-être au moins deux
méchants et apprendre à noter une
reprise par des consultations au
contraire plus que pleine avec ce
qu'elle est un peu de retard par leur
rendez vous donc là c'est pas mon
sentiment en tout cas pour les gens qui
viennent consulter à l'hôpital mais ceux
là viennent donc évidemment les efforts
doivent porter sur les autres n'ont rien
tout ce que vous avez prononcé le mot
c'est le mot courrier alors je vous
propose sa présente qu'on regarde un
reportage qui étaient réalisés au sein
du centre de coordination des dépistages
des cancers des yvelines depuis 2004 le
dépistage organisé du cancer du sein a
été généralisé dans les yvelines
quarante mille dépistages ont lieu tous
les ans grâce à cette antenne du centre
régional de coordination des dépistages
des cancers
un service public qui accompagne les
femmes bel âge de 50 ans donc on reçoit
notre les femmes reçoivent notre
invitation
elle veut
elles prennent rendez-vous dans un
centre de radiologie donc nous on
adresse avec l'invitation une liste de
radiologue agréé au dépistage organisé
et les femmes vont passer donc tous les
deux ans si tout se passe bien
une mammographie de dépistage organisé
jusqu'à l'âge de 74 ans les centres de
coordination des dépistages des cancers
est aussi là pour contrôler une deuxième
fois les résultats des mammographies on
reçoit les mammographies après que les
femmes aient répondu à nos invitations
de dépistage organisé et est passé dans
un premier temps leur mammographie dans
un centre de radiologie du département
où d'ailleurs partir du moment les zones
été considéré normal par le premier
lecteur dans le centre d'imagerie elles
viennent à la structure de gestion pour
être lue par un second radiologue avant
d'être retournés aux femmes avec la
conclusion finale
la dizaine de personnes qui travaillent
dans cette structure accompagne donc les
femmes pendant tout le processus de la
sensibilisation de l'importance du
dépistage jusqu'au résultat
au total 250 femmes sont dépistées
positives au cancer du sein chaque année
dans les yvelines
grâce au dépistage généralisé dr combler
ce qu'on peut rappeler l'importance de
ce dépistage parce que c'est le mot
qu'on prononce depuis le début de
l'émission alors dépistage comme celui
d'acteur berne où il a l'intérêt de
dépister les tumeurs les plus petites
possibles dont il se guérir ont le mieux
est actuellement c'est quand même la
plus grosse partie de de pourvoyeur de
enfin de diagnostic de cancer du sang
vient du dépistage et donc c'est tant
mieux c'est ce qui a permis d'améliorer
son pronostic
donc effectivement si on diminue le
dépistage on va diminuer le nombre de
cancers dépistés et en plus on va tenir
le nom de se prononce
on peut guérir le mieux donc
tout est le repose sur ce qui a permis
le progrès dans le pronostic de la
maladie
comment comment il se fait ce dépistage
on a parlé de radiographie il y à une
palpation annuel à faire par un
professionnel de santé
dès l'âge de 25 ans quelles sont les
différentes étapes alors le dépistage
mais effectivement il peut être les
cliniques
évidemment la consultation gynécologique
annuel avec la passion est recommandé
pour toutes les femmes effectivement en
fonction de partir de 5 ans comme vous
l'avez souligné
ils vont nous identifie les familles qui
en suit et des cas plus ou moins à
risque pour le faire à ce qu'on appelle
à prendre dépistage mammographie qui
peut être soit individuel soit organisée
dans le cadre du dépistage organisé
effectivement les passants sont invités
directement par les centres de dépistage
entre l'âge de 50 et 74 ans
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut commencer
les mammographies forcément qu'à 50 ans
après le clinicien que la passion va
devoir aller voir un gynécologue un tous
les ans va juger au cas par cas selon le
risque familiale risque individuel de la
patiente de la nécessité ou non de
commencer le dépistage mammographie le
plus jeune on a éteint on a été un peu
alarmiste avec des chiffres assez
conséquents mais on l'a dit en plus
c'est un cancer qu'on sait guérir tout
sur vie varie de 80 90 % sur ça qu'il
faut continuer à se faire dépister dans
docteur compte si vous souhaitez
remontée en août madame vers nous oui il
faut il faut c'est important de se faire
dépister de se faire épices dépister
tous les deux ans ce dépistage l'ena son
efficacité que s'il est refait
régulièrement tous les deux ans puisque
bas on sait qu'un concert mais à peu
près
une dizaine d'années à se développer et
le gain par le dépistage organisé en
fait entre le moment où on va faire une
mammographie donc une radio des saints
où on va percevoir des anomalies
radiologiques qui vont conduire aller
plus loin dans les examens et donc ils
vont permettre de dépister un petit
cancer et le moment où on aurait en fait
une masse qui serait uniquement palpable
en fait c'est un délai de deux à trois
ans et du coup tout le bénéfice de ce
dépistage chez de refaire ce contrôle
régulièrement tous les deux à tous les
deux dans un pour justement pour pour
pour permettre au cours de la vie d'une
femme de voilà d'éviter des victimes
afin de trouver très très tôt un cancer
à dresde et à jean alesi pardon mais je
voulais rajouter aussi l'intérêt du
dépistage organisé qui est proposé à
partir de 50 ans alors pourquoi partir
de 50 ans c'est parce que 75 % des
cancers du sein surviennent chez des
femmes
après 50 ans et sa fréquence augmente
avec l'âge donc c'est vraiment pour ça
que on propose ce dépistage généralisé à
toutes les femmes à partir de 50 ans et
puis un dépistage organisé c'est un
dépistage qui et qui bénéficie donc
comme on l'a dit dans le reportage les
deux perdants seraient d'une seconde
lecture
il faut savoir que cette seconde lecture
des clichés par un don par un deuxième
radiologue permet de dépister 6% de
cancer enfin dans le dépistage organisé
6 % des cancers de trouver dans l'épi
stages organisés le sont grâce à la
seconde lecture
et il ya aussi un contrôle qualité du
matériel radiologique utiliser qui
permet d'avoir un matériel donc de
qualité à la fois pour assurer un bon
dépistage mais en même temps s'assurer
que il n'y a pas trop de queue du fait
que judaïsme et des radios donc il ya
des régions qui sont envoyées que la
quantité de rentrer de rayon qui qui est
dit que la femme reçoit pendant l'examen
est très faible et donc ne provoque pas
de risques liés à ces rayons non il ya
tout soit on sait aussi que outre la
peur de la pandémie d'attraper une autre
maladie c'est parfois l'aspect financier
qui va bloquer les personnes à se faire
soigner le dépistage organisé est pris
en charge à 100% dans l'assurance
maladie est-ce que lors de vos groupes
de parole vous en profiter pour rappeler
ceci ou les professionnels de santé
viennent comment ça se passe oui lors de
nos groupes de parole les professionnels
de santé viennent on fait le groupe de
parole avec des professionnels de santé
tels que l'amour et la ligue contre le
cancer une qualité des digues là donc ça
nous a beaucoup aidés et ça nous a
beaucoup appris parce que le cancer
c'est vrai c'est quand on entend le mot
cancer on a peur on s'imagine tout de
suite qu'il n'y aura pas d'issue
là on a compris que si on y pense un peu
plus tôt on a la chance de réussir deux
que le cancer va on pourra le guérir
quand l'éléphant ont compris et c'est
grâce à ces professionnels qui nous a
vraiment appris beaucoup de choses et
autour de points café on le faisait
tous les mois tous les quinze jours
entre un groupe de parole avec un
professionnel donc vraiment ça nous a
beaucoup appris et on a moins peur c'est
vrai ça fait peur mais on a moins peur
il faut aussi plaindre un peu plus tôt
au lieu d'attendre que ça s'aggrave
est-ce que vous travaillez plus
précisément avec la mairie des mureaux
pour renforcer voilà qu'en cette période
le dépistage doit continuer à se faire
il est très important
oui on travaille avec
le ccs donc
on a beaucoup travaillé avec le cs de la
ville des mureaux et
on a beaucoup de partenaires qui ont
participé pour nous soutenir donc sur la
sensibilisation qu'on fait au niveau de
la vie et on a même pu me monter une
pièce de théâtre pour vraiment que les
gens savent que le transfère ya il ya
une solution
il faut aussi prendre un peu plus tôt au
lieu d'atteindre donc ça c'est vraiment
ça nous a beaucoup aidé ça beaucoup aidé
la population aussi justement là on
vient d'entendre il ya des groupes de
paroles qui se créent dans certaines
communes il ya des activités plus
culturelles mais ce que c'est aussi un
moyen pousser ce dépistage asphalt
est-ce qu'il faut aussi cette année
peut-être se renouveler dans les
animations pour pousser les femmes à
comprendre qu'il faut se faire dépister
tout à fait on a dû annuler d'habitude
il y à de très nombreuses manifestations
des courses démarche des rencontres qui
sont organisées cette année bien entendu
avec le co vider avec en plus la période
là convient en octobre avec un
renforcement des mesures sanitaires
beaucoup de ces actions n'ont pas pu
avoir lieu donc il ya eu beaucoup
d'imagination pour créer en fait pas mal
de d'actions via via les réseaux sociaux
à travers où on a développé notamment
des affiches avec un qr code au niveau
régional qui permet au jour de la
chandeleur code d'accès des mets à la
notre site internet pour accéder à de
l'information sur ce dépistage
il ya des courses qui ont été organisées
par la ligue dans certains dans certains
villes ou dans certains dans certains
départements pour sensibiliser les gens
des courses virtuelles
on a fait aussi des groupes de formation
de personnes via des webinars où on a pu
former des personnes relais au niveau de
mériller au niveau de bénévoles donc on
a essayé de développer un certain nombre
d'outils innovants pour pallier aux
on puisse pas malheureusement cette
rencontre individuelle avec les dents
sur dans l'espace public et le message
aussi qui est important mais je rebondis
sur ce que vient de dire madame c'est
qu'en fait il faut que les femmes
deviennent actrices de leur santé et de
la lutte contre le cancer on n'est pas
passif c'est une bonne nouvelle
actuellement avec la connaissance
actuelle qu'on a c'est qu'à la fois on
peut faire de la prévention puisque 40%
des cancers peuvent être évités grâce à
une activité sportive une alimentation
équilibrée l'arrêt du tabac la
diminution d'alcool donc agir sur tous
ces facteurs de risque en faisant de
l'activité physique en équilibrant son
alimentation
eh ben c'est une façon d'agir contre le
cancer
et puis à participer au dépistage ne pas
tarder qu'on reçoit son courrier
d'invitation pour prendre rendez vous
chez le radiologue pour faire son
dépistage manière régulière c'est aussi
une façon en tant que femme d'être
active passe au cancer dr combat au
centre hospitalier de versailles aussi
on a cherché à informer différemment
pour pouvoir continuer à dépister
normalement chaque année dans tient un
stand pour octobre rose dans le hall de
l'hôpital et donc il s'est tenu cette
année puisque ben voilà qu'au respect
des gestes mariait remet donc ça a été
ça a été maintenue on essaie de
maintenir voilà pour effectivement tout
soit fait pour continuer à promouvoir le
dépistage plus possible justement dans
ces journées là quels sont les termes
utilisés ce sont c'est vous même qui est
présente ce sont des sages femmes se
sont justement on multiplie la la les
professionnels de santé pour montrer que
c'est tout un monde aussi le dépistage
ce n'est pas qu'un jeu nicolas ou autre
oui tout à fait donc les sages femmes
mamans participent beaucoup dépistage
puisqu'elle
elle voit beaucoup passante dans le
cadre du suivi des patientes qui
chantent ils n'ont pas de problèmes
particuliers de pathologie particulière
et qui se sont vus pour des
consultations de suivi
effectivement face à la pénurie un peu
de médecins gynécologues en ville et
voilà les professionnels hospitaliers en
fonction et judo dédiées à la chirurgie
ou quand il ya déjà une pathologie qui
est des deux sticks et mais elle est
cette femme participe beaucoup au
dépistage tout à fait voilà dans le sens
dans notre sens il ya aussi on fait
venir des associations
oui c'est un fait et finalement on voit
l'association de madame sow fait venir
des médecins pour rassurer
est-ce que vous même en tant que
praticien de santé vous allez vers les
associations pour qu'il est vraiment une
coordination du message dr connors
dadolle à l'écrit ne s'est pas oui du
centre hospitalier mais donc du coup
effectivement passé d' important que
l'information puisse être relayée dans
les deux sens que les professionnels
vers les patientes et que effectivement
et patiente n'ai pas peur d'aller berg
et professionnelle ou parce que madame
sur votre association travaille contre
l' isolement notamment celle des femmes
et la santé c'est très important
j'imagine oui contre les allemands à des
fins et pour la réussite de contre
l'échec scolaire au site et des enfants
donc
là vraiment ce que je peux rajouter
c'était comment on fait lord et on ne
sait pas aujourd'hui sur un confinement
ou pas donc ça vraiment vous voulez
professionnel on aimerait bien avoir une
piste comment faire comment renouer les
contacts
comment comment on pourrait reprendre
les les groupes de parole avec les
professionnels et les femmes qui en ont
besoin
je pense que tout le monde a besoin
d'eux de se soigner se faire dépister
donc ça c'est une question que je pose
aux médecins quelles solutions
nous allons pour les associations alors
je vais vous donner la parole dr vers
nous parce que l'association de travail
notamment avec le crc de cd&v en
quelques secondes si vous avez déjà une
piste ou peut-être qu'il faut attendre
les prochaines déclarations le président
emmanuel macron s'adressera notamment
français ce soir
est ce que finalement tout est en
suspens alors non tout n'est pas rose en
suspens est ce qu'il faut faire c'est
vraiment utilisé mais là malheureusement
on sait que le contact virtuel à travers
voilà les les connexions internet les
tchatches c'est un moyen mais
effectivement ça suffit pas parfois les
gens besoin de se rencontrer en vrai et
ça c'est une vraie difficulté qui est
compliqué maintenant donc bon utiliser
des outils des groupes de parole je sais
qu'il ya beaucoup de psychologues par
exemple qui ont continué à avoir pendant
pendant confinement à avoir des
consultations en visio c'est pas l'idéal
mais bon c'est peut-être mieux que rien
et donc peut-être envisager des groupes
de paroles en visio ça peut être une
solution dans cette période très
complexe et c'est sur ces mots qu'on va
s'arrêter merci à toutes les trois
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
on l'aura bien compris le dépistage est
nécessaire quand vous avez votre
courrier
rendez vous chez votre professionnel de
santé allez chez votre professionnel
chaque année quand c'est nécessaire au 6
octobre rose ça dure jusqu'au 30 octobre
prochain
pour compléter cette actualité vous
pouvez
voir l'entretien réalisé par eléonore
sinoquet dans le 7-8 journal du 7
octobre dernier et les missions vous
pouvez la revoir sur le site internet où
notre application mobile de cette
société revient la semaine prochaine
[Musique]